you guys probably know by now I'm a bit
obsessed with names trigonometry what
does it mean like it's actually there in
my name let's just start with the
beginning try me on go on
does it know what God actually made it
means angles angles just like polygons
right I know I used to think of that as
many sighted but actually it means many
so a Trigon is a three angled shape now
when you see you know on the tree on
there
I'm a tree um there's a few different
like off sort of um suffixes you can see
like there's old graffiti like geography
right there's ology like topology and
then there's on the tree what does this
mean we don't tend us we don't tend to
see this in many contexts
there's optometry optometry so it's kind
of what's that about this geometry um
you can put you in front of any of these
by the way geometry geology it may help
if you know another word that we use
which comes from the same faces namely
metric so metric is about measurements
okay if I say you know one of the
metrics on XYZ okay or if we talk about
the metric system it literally means the
system that you used to measure stuff
okay so this is about measurement
measurement
so essentially this means okay it's
about measuring triangles and that's
kind of all the name implies this is
where trigonometry begins but it's not
where trigonometry and in fact
trigonometry kind of has a way of
getting into everything example if you
haven't think about anything that
operates in cycles right anything that's
periodic and it repeats so over and over
again right when you have something
that's periodic and that repeats
repetitive we have a name for this
that's based on this [ __ ] we call it
cyclic right like it goo the rounded
circle or every circle if I were to
actually do any measurement of what's
happening in this circle every circle is
actually built up of a series of
triangles right so anywhere you find
cyclic things periodic things things
that happen over and over again despite
the fact that it doesn't look like it
has to do the triangles you get
trigonometry in there right so when we
move on to simple harmonic motion which
is kind of things moving up and down or
left and right or round and round it's
all in terms of trigonometric
trigonometric functions right so that's
in terms of things that go around around
or oscillate is one other quick example
because you know it's about angle
measurement anytime anything happens in
angles trigonometry will be involved
right quick example thinking of simple
harmonic motion the next big application
of geometry that you find in the
extension one course is what we call
projectile motion so if you have an
object right and you fire it at a
certain angle like this at a certain
velocity and so on right you want to
understand what's going on here like how
high am go and how far it'll go all
those kinds of things are understood in
terms of trigonometry right even things
like if you want to go a little bit
further in this is all extension 1 in
the extension 2 topic called circular
motion we look at things that are just
going back to the circle we look at
things that do this go around around the
map
now clearly you can sort of think about
this as like a Lord's a cycle of kinds
right but it's not what we call simple
harmonic motion simple harmonic motion
is just in one dimension so it's up down
or left right whereas this is in two
dimensions and now you're feeling very
very sleepy
now hold on what's happening Tuesday
night if I use my conveniently drawn
circle here I've got my um I've got my
street holding something to a center of
motion that's like my finger in the
middle right and then you've got the
keys flying around there right what's a
people died everything now have a look
at that thing what's it doing it's going
around the circle and it's motion is
described by that line there right so
it's constantly going around if I get to
here it's going to be going that way we
get to here it's going that way each of
these lines is a tangent okay now what's
going on here all of these different
angles of motion right we compare things
like what's is called linear velocity
versus angular velocity all of these
types of things right they're all built
or base these triangles so despite the
fact that you know where's the triangle
in this thing when I spin around right
answer is there everywhere once you have
eyes to see them okay so trigonometry
begins with very very simple things but
it's because triangles are hidden
everywhere trigonometry sort of gets
everywhere okay